in beirut lebanon people are protesting
there against the government
after a giant explosion killed more than
150 people demonstrators claim official
corruption
led to tuesday's blast which destroyed
thousands of homes
and large amounts of the country's food
supply mts tayab is in beirut where a
massive
international relief effort is underway
well the u.s military is racing here to
help the people of lebanon
three cargo planes full of desperately
needed supplies are on their way
as grief here turns to fury
as darkness fell on the streets of a
shattered beirut
protesters confronted lebanese security
forces
the rage follows revelations the
government knew about the 2700 tons of
ammonium nitrate
being stored at the city's port
and did nothing despite repeated
warnings from customs officials
the material had been left to rot
this still smoldering bomb site has
become something of a morbid meeting
point for those devastated by the blast
like tatiana whose father worked at the
port
she hasn't seen him since the explosion
but is convinced he's still alive
i think he's there but i think if we
continue to work slowly probably
time will run out she blames lebanon's
leaders for failing her and her father
my dad is underground you don't know if
he's breathing if he's in pain families
are being shattered now because
of a mistake they they did across beirut
are harrowing stories of survival
a texas-born doctor is seen here
soothing her daughter in the back of a
packed ambulance
four-year-old iman was badly injured
after their home was all but destroyed
in the explosion
it was apocalyptic scenes
dust debris everywhere
jelani is no stranger to conflict zones
having worked as a humanitarian aid
doctor for years
but never had she seen scenes like this
i was thinking
this is either something bigger than war
something is happening
now there are growing calls to overthrow
the government and mass protests
are planned for tomorrow a stark warning
to lebanon's leaders
that what happened here won't soon be
forgotten
jeff mts higher than beirut thank you
very much